a unos 60 km al oeste de moscú en
zvenigorod los estantes de esta tienda
están en su mayoría abastecidos con
productos locales las marcas
estadounidenses de refrescos están entre
los únicos artículos importados está
cocacola por ejemplo fue embotellada en
kazajistán
los precios de estos refrescos han
subido no sé si voy a reponerlos es
demasiado caro
para muchos rusos el mayor impacto de
las sanciones occidentales hasta ahora
ha sido el aumento de los precios
los precios del café han subido entre un
15 y un 20 por ciento pero debido a la
retirada de grandes marcas como
mcdonald's estoy recibiendo más clientes
y es que algunos sectores se han visto
más afectados que otros este taller de
reparación de automóviles en las afueras
de moscú dice que están luchando para
mantener los costos a medida que las
piezas de los coches extranjeros se
encarecen el mantenimiento se está
volviendo muy difícil un cambio de
aceite para un coche alemán de lujo
cuesta ahora casi mil euros por ahora
todavía tenemos piezas de repuesto pero
los precios se han triplicado incluso
cuadruplicado
mientras la inflación se dispara muchos
rusos se preparan para tiempos difíciles
y se empiezan a abastecer con
suministros